In den 16 Jahren zwischen 1972 und 1988
wurden 25.449 wissenschaftlich dokumentierte Versuche in Remote Viewing,
also in Fernwahrnehmung, durchgeführt.
Die Auswertung dieser Ergebnisse hat gezeigt:
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass außersinnliche Wahrnehmung reiner Zufall ist,
liegt bei 1 zu 16,3 Billionen.
[Musik]
Ja, herzlich willkommen!
Mein Name ist Carsten Ohrmann und ich freue mich hier
zu sein.
Wisst ihr, was mein größtes Problem ist?
Ich bin gefangen!
Gefangen in Raum und Zeit. 18 Minuten
schön hier auf dem Teppich bleiben.
Mein Leben lang immer nur Erwartungen
erfüllen. Niemals aus der Reihe tanzen.
Ich hasse das!
Und dann diese weisen Sprüche: Liebe dich selbst!
So eine gequirlte Sülze! Wie soll
ich mich denn selbst lieben, wenn ich
nicht einmal wirklich weiß, wer ich bin?!
Und woher soll ich denn wissen wer ich
bin, wenn ich nicht einmal verstanden
habe, wie diese Realität hier um uns
herum funktioniert?!
Liebe deinen Nächsten! Piep, piep, piep -
wir haben uns alle lieb!
Das macht doch keinen Sinn!!
Vor ca. sechs Wochen war ich abends in
Frankenthal in einem Raum mit ungefähr
30 weiteren Menschen, von denen ich die
allermeisten gar nicht kannte.
Es ist heiß und das Display der Klimaanlage
sagt: Stufe 6.
Ich bin nervös, weil ich weiß: Heute geht es um mich.
Unmittelbar
vor mir steht ein Mann. Ungefähr meine
Größe, mein Alter, meine Statur, kurze
Hosen. Und er sieht mir direkt in die
Augen und er zittert vor Anspannung.
Ich
kann förmlich spüren, wie er innerlich kocht.
Plötzlich schlägt er mir gegen die Brust
und schreit:
Verdammt, jetzt spür mich endlich!!!
Er ist der Stellvertreter meiner
Wut.
Wir sind in meiner Familienaufstellung
und ich erkenne erst jetzt, wie wütend
und wie unheimlich traurig bin. Ich bin
wütend auf meine Eltern. Eine Wut, die ich
seit 40 Jahren unterdrückt habe. Und ich
bin wütend auf mich selbst, weil ich
immer nur eine Rolle gespielt habe. Und
ich bin so traurig, so traurig, weil ich
nie ich selbst war. Aber wer bin ich
eigentlich?? Auf meinem Personalausweis
steht: Carsten Ohrmann, 48 Jahre, 182 groß,
blaue Augen. Auf meiner Visitenkarte
steht: Unternehmensberater und Coach. Und
in meinem Lebenslauf könnt ihr lesen:
Diplom-Maschinenbau-Ingenieur, Sustainable
Business Studium in Cambridge, Zulassung
als Heilpraktiker für Psychotherapie und
Partner und Senior Manager einer großen
IT-Unternehmensberatung mit 40.000
Mitarbeitern weltweit.
Aber bin ich das alles? Bin ich mein
Körper? Bin ich mein Beruf? Bin ich meine
Familie? Bin ich mein Haus, mein Geld, mein
Auto? Oder sind das alles nur Erfahrungen
die ich mache??
Ich weiß nur, dass ich Angst habe. Angst
vor Ablehnung. Angst davor, nicht genug zu sein.
Ist diese Angst vielleicht sogar die
Triebfeder für meinen penetranten
Ehrgeiz und Perfektionismus? Ich muss
immer alles richtig machen. Immer 1000-prozentig!
Warum? Damit ich nicht
abgelehnt werde. Verdanke ich vielleicht
sogar meine gesamte Karriere nur diese
Angst? Und jetzt stehe ich hier, heute vor
euch und ich habe wieder Angst! Angst vor
Reputationsverlust. Angst davor, mich
lächerlich zu machen.
Aber ich kann nicht anders! Weil wenn
ich endlich aufhören möchte, mich zu
verleugnen, wenn ich endlich aufhören
möchte, eine Rolle zu spielen,
dann muss ich dieses Tabu jetzt hier brechen:
Als Führungskraft
bin ich sehr wahrscheinlich nicht normal!
Ja, ich habe eine Familienaufstellung
gemacht. Und ja,
ich bin gottfroh, dass ich das getan habe.
Ja, in meiner Arbeit reden
wir auch über Gefühle.
Angst, Wut, Traurigkeit sind keine Tabu-Themen. Ganz
im Gegenteil:
Sie sind häufig sogar der Schlüssel für die persönliche
Weiterentwicklung.
Aber das ist noch nicht alles. Es wird
noch viel schlimmer.
Ich bekenne mich hiermit öffentlich schuldig,
mich seit vielen Jahren mit paranormalen Phänomenen zu beschäftigen.
Ich interessiere mich brennend für wissenschaftliche Anomalien,
für nicht-lokales Bewusstsein, für Parapsychologie, für alternative Heilmethoden usw.
Ich habe dafür im Jahr 2012, Ende 2012,
sogar meine eigene Senior
Executive Karriere an den Nagel gehängt,
nur um mich damit wirklich intensiv zu
beschäftigen.
Ja und wenn wir schon dabei sind: Ich
interessiere mich auch
für Spiritualität, Schamanismus und alte
Weisheis-Traditionen.
Ich habe mir sogar meinen kosmischen
Ursprungsnamen channeln lassen!
Bin ich jetzt vollständig bescheuert,
oder ist das noch normal?
Was ist eigentlich normal?
In einem Nudistendorf ist es vollständig normal, dass du nackt in den Supermarkt rennst.
Ist normal deshalb nicht relativ?
Ist normal nicht eine Frage von Ort und Zeit?
Noch bis vor 150 Jahren wusste niemand
auf dieser Welt, dass es
elektromagnetische Felder gibt.
Heute können wir ohne Radio, Fernsehen, Mikrowelle, Handy, Satelliten-Navigationssystem und so weiter
überhaupt nicht mehr leben.
Erst vor 100 Jahren wurde hier in
Deutschland das Frauenwahlrecht
eingeführt.
Für uns ist doch heute vollständig
normal, dass sich Frauen politisch engagieren.
Am 21 Juli 1969 hat Neil Armstrong als
erster Mensch einen Fuß auf den Mond
gesetzt.
Heute ist bemannte Raumfahrt für uns
vollständig normal.
Und erst 1989, also vor 30 Jahren,
das war das Jahr wo ich meinen
Führerschein gemacht habe, da wurde das
Internet erfunden.
Und das Internet hat unser Leben noch mal vollständig verändert.
Ohne das internet hätten wir diese ganzen Themen nicht, mit denen wir uns beschäftigen:
Digitalisierung, künstliche Intelligenz, Datenschutz und so weiter. Das gäbe es ohne das Internet gar nicht.
Aber die Frage ist doch:
Was kommt als nächstes?
Was ist denn morgen normal?
Die Stefanie Menzel hat in den letzten 15 Jahren mehr als 2000 große Familienaufstellungen geleitet.
Das bedeutet da waren mehrere
Menschen als Stellvertreter
für Gefühle, für Personen, für Vorgänge usw. jeweils präsent.
Für die Stefanie ist es vollständig normal, in ihren Aufstellungsarbeiten immer und immer und immer
wieder zu beobachten, dass die
Stellvertreter genau die richtigen
Gefühle und Informationen haben, ohne
dass überhaupt irgend jemand erklären
kann, wie das funktioniert.
Professor Bill Bengston aus New York hat eine Methode zur Energieheilung entwickelt.
Für den Bill ist es vollständig normal, dass er in seinen Laborversuchen Mäuse von Krebs heilen kann.
Und zwar nur, in dem er die Hände an den
Käfig legt!
Angelika Selina Braun aus Berlin hat mehrere Jahre mit einem kolumbianischen Schamanen
namens Taguari verbracht. Für Selina ist es heute
vollständig normal, sich mit geistigen
Wesen einer Welt zu verbinden, zu der ich
überhaupt gar keinen Zugang habe.
Ich persönlich kenne Stefanie, Bill, Selina
und noch weitere solche Menschen sehr gut.
Und glaubt mir: Ich glaube, das sind
keine Spinner!
Ich kenne auch Paul Smith aus Utah in den
USA sehr gut.
Paul ist ein ehemaliger, also pensionierter, Major des US-Militär-Geheimdienstes.
Er war Teil eines
Forschungsprojektes, was das US Militär
gemeinsam mit dem Stanford Research
Institute durchgeführt hat.
Die wollten herausfinden, ob außer-sinnliche Wahrnehmung wirklich existiert
und wie man außer-sinnliche Wahrnehmung, zu Zeiten des kalten Krieges, für Spionage nutzen kann.
Dieses Projekt ist inzwischen declassified,
d.h. es ist nicht mehr…,
unterliegt nicht mehr der Geheimhaltung.
In den 16 Jahren zwischen 1972 und 1988
wurden 25.449 wissenschaftlich
dokumentierte versuche in Remote Viewing,
also in Fernwahrnehmung durchgeführt.
Die Auswertung dieser Ergebnisse hat
gezeigt:
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass außersinnliche Wahrnehmung reiner Zufall ist,
liegt bei 1 zu 16,3 Billionen.
Nur mal zum Vergleich: Die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass wir sechs Richtige im Lotto haben,
liegt bei 1 zu ungefähr 15,5 Millionen.
16,3 Billionen können wir uns nicht vorstellen.
Stellt euch mal vor ihr habt eine Kiste, die ist vier Meter breit, die ist vier Meter lang, und einen Meter hoch.
Und diese Kiste ist randvoll gefüllt mit
Sand.
In dieser Kiste sind 16 Billionen Sandkörner.
Das kommt ungefähr hin.
Ich bin Perfektionist.
Das ist alles feinster Sand. Blütenrein.
Alles weiße Sandkörner.
Bis auf ein einziges schwarzes Schaf. In dieser Kiste ist genau ein einziges Sandkorn:
Ein pechrabenschwarzes Sandkorn, irgendwo in dieser
Kiste und ihr wisst nicht wo.
Und jetzt geht ihr her, ihr verbindet
euch die Augen, ihr taucht in diese Kiste,
ihr wühlt, ihr entscheidet euch, ihr zieht ein Sandkorn raus und...
die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ihr jetzt dieses eine schwarze Sandkorn in den Fingern haltet
ist genauso gering, wie die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass
außersinnliche Wahrnehmung nicht existiert.
Mit anderen Worten:
Außersinnliche Wahrnehmung
funktioniert wahrscheinlich.
Und man kann sie erlernen.
Bitte versteht mich nicht falsch! Ich
möchte gar nicht, dass ihr mir das hier alles glaubt.
Ich möchte, dass ihr euch
euer eigenes Bild macht.
Da draußen rennen jede Menge Spinner rum
und da draußen wird unheimlich vielen Müll erzählt.
Aber vielleicht ist da irgendwo auch manchmal noch ein Stückchen Wahrheit dazwischen.
Und es ist jetzt deine
Aufgabe herauszufinden,
aus diesem ganzen Puzzle von
informationen,
dein eigenes persönliches Weltbild
zusammen zu bauen.
Dein persönliches Big Picture.
Und dabei kannst du selber entscheiden, welches Puzzle-Teil für dich plausibel ist,
also welches Puzzlestück Du verwenden willst und welches auch nicht.
Stellt euch die
richtigen Fragen!
Und versucht unabhängig, eure eigenen Antworten darauf zu finden.
Die Fragen, die ich mir stelle sind:
Wie funktioniert diese Realität?
Welche Rolle spielt Bewusstsein?
Gibt es so etwas wie ein Informations-Feld?
So eine Art zentrales Cloud-Bewusstsein?
Und wenn ja, wie interagiert
mein kleines Insel-Bewusstsein hier mit
diesem zentralen Cloud-Bewusstsein?
Ist es eine Frage von Zugriffsrechten?
Kann ich mehr Zugriffsrechte bekommen?
Und wie hängt denn jetzt dieses zentrale Cloud-Bewusstsein mit der Materie zusammen?
Kann Bewusstsein Materie beeinflussen?
Bin ich ein Körper mit Bewusstsein?
Oder vielleicht Bewusstsein mit einem Körper?
Und wenn ich Bewusstsein mit einem Körper bin
und du bist Bewusstsein mit einem Körper,
sind wir dann vielleicht das gleiche Bewusstsein?
Bin ich du? Bist du ich?
Sind wir eins? Sind wir Gott?
Und wenn ja, was hätte das für Auswirkungen auf unser
Leben, auf unser Business und auf die Welt?
Ich erinnere mich noch gut an einen
Anruf von einem Herrn Müller.
Das war ein später Freitagabend,
irgendwann im April oder Mai diesen Jahres, ich weiss es nicht mehr ganz genau.
Nach ein paar Minuten Telefonat sagt der Müller zu mir:
Sagen sie Herr Ohrmann, sind sie eigentlich Mitglied einer Sekte oder einer Geheimgesellschaft?
Und ich sag: Nein Herr Müller!
Ich bin Ingenieur - das ist was anderes!
Ich bin Hardcore-Rationalist. Ich betreibe meine eigene Forschung und Entwicklung.
Das ist Teil meiner DNA.
Da draußen laufen so viele Leute rum, die uns was über Spiritualität erzählen wollen.
Und ich versuche zu verstehen, wie Spiritualität funktioniert.
Ich baue doch auch keine Brücke und schicke da Autos drüber,
ohne dass ich die Statik vorher zwei mal durchgerechnet habe.
Dann sagt der Herr Müller noch:
Wissen sie eigentlich, warum ich mir ihr E-Book nicht runter geladen habe?
Ich so: Nee, warum?
Er sagt: Weil das in dem Verkaufsrang unter esoterische Bücher gelistet ist.
Ich so: Ah, das ist ja spannend, weil ich weiß ganz genau,
dass als ich das E-Book
hochgeladen habe, habe ich nicht die
Kategorie Esoterik dafür ausgewählt.
Aber wo wir gerade beim Thema sind: Wisst ihr eigentlich, was Esoterik bedeutet?
Esoterik bedeutet: Wissen, dass nur einem kleinen Kreis zugänglich ist.
Im Business nennen wir Wissen, was nur einem kleinen Kreis zugänglich ist, wie...?!
Genau! Einen Wettbewerbsvorteil!
Wenn da also nicht Esoterik drauf stehen würde,
sondern potenzieller Wettbewerbsvorteil,
dann würden sich da viel viel mehr
Menschen für interessieren.
Aber nein, wir stehen natürlich auf dem Standpunkt:
Nein! Wir sind doch Führungskräfte!
Da kann man doch bei so einem Thema
nicht vorangehen.
Doch!!  Können wir!  Yes we can!
Ihr müsst es ja nicht gleich jedem auf
die Nase binden.
Habe ich ja am Anfang auch nicht gemacht.
Übrigens weiß ich inzwischen auch, dass der Herr Müller gar nicht wirklich Müller heißt,
weil wir nämlich gerade dabei sind einen Workshop zu
organisieren, mit seiner Strategie-Abteilung,
um dann herauszuarbeiten,
welche potenziellen Chancen und Risiken
dieses neue Weltbild für sein
Unternehmen mit sich bringen könnte.
Warum erzähle ich euch das alles?
Ich bin mittlerweile davon überzeugt, dass sich die Welt, in der wir leben,
in den nächsten Jahren - vielleicht Jahrzehnten - noch mal massiv verändern wird.
Und dabei rede ich jetzt nicht über die Auswirkungen von weiteren technologischen Entwicklungen,
wie wir sie immer wieder hören.
Oder auch die Kombination von Digitalisierung,
Globalisierung, künstlicher Intelligenz,
Mass Data Management und so weiter. Das wird alles passieren. Keine Frage.
Ich rede über eine weitere Veränderung. Einen weiteren massiven Wandel.
Und zwar einen Bewusstseinswandel
in der Gesellschaft.
Ich persönlich glaube, immer mehr
Menschen werden erkennen,
dass unser derzeitiges Verständnis davon, wie die Welt funktioniert, nicht mehr 100-prozentig richtig ist.
Ich glaube, wir werden erkennen, dass Bewusstsein eine wesentlich größere Rolle
bei der Erklärung der Realität spielt, als wir das bislang vermutet haben.
Und das hat Auswirkungen. Diese Erkenntnisse werden gestützt
durch wissenschaftliche Forschungsergebnisse.
Das heißt, was passiert ist, dass
moderne Wissenschaft und alte Weisheits-Traditionen anfangen zusammenzuwachsen.
Und dieses Zusammenwachsen hat eine Auswirkung auf unser Leben,
auf das Business und auf die Welt.
Wir sind Führungskräfte und ich bin davon
überzeugt wir tragen eine Verantwortung.
Ich glaube wir sollten wissen, was da
draußen gerade passiert.
Und ich glaube, wir sollten unsere eigene
Entscheidung treffen,
ob wir diesen Bewusstseinswandel in der Gesellschaft
jetzt aktiv unterstützen wollen,
wie mein Herr Müller, oder nicht.
Mein Name ist Carsten Maranius Ohrmann. Nein, ...
ich bin Carsten Maranius Ohrmann.
Und ich habe mich entschieden.
Ich danke euch fürs zuhören.
[Applaus]
Carsten Ohrmann!
[www.CarstenOhrmann.com]
[Musik]